[Musique]
le jour de halloween que disent les
petits sorciers des petits monstres aux
portes des maisons des jouets ou un gros
mot et bonbons ou un sort et je vois que
la palme revient à ses vannes à des
bonbons ou le coc vide
je trouve ça un peu mieux quand même
qu'en tirent au sort parce que c'est
évidemment
la
réponse est oui je pense que je suis
trop me soucier est trop gentil c'est
entouré pas viré ouais parce que tout ça
c'est bien de garder jennifer troncy une
aventure parce que ça sert tellement à
rien qu'à tout moment tu peux la rareté
ou ça me fait 9 millions à 28 milles ça
nous fait vingt deux mille
et
28000 29 - 9 me pour toi ça fait vingt
deux nuits et fléchit me ou 1 lui
a
valu
68 mètres c'est notre chiffre du jour et
c'est la distance à laquelle un
stéphanois a inscrit le but de la
journée ou peut-être de la saison en
ligue 1 saint-etienne était mené 1 2
roddick n 10 s'est emparé d'une année
ferme de points red ou si ça ne bouge
plus et goldorak soldat peut tenter de
le bouger notre bras ne bouge plus non
plus c'est ça ça va être pratique ce
soir à la maison magique là dedans c'est
qu'on peut faire ça avec tous les
membres du corps
le démon
picholine à morteau
[Musique]
partant il que la proton son fils quand
on mange pas et que je sois là
c'est quand même
j'ai dit on est fiers parce que
franchement être si bonne sur la
société vous échapper à une casserole
aulas lors il ya là dedans c'était
d'ouvrir cette boîte on dirait une urne
et je vais un des trois
[Applaudissements]
noms soient pas aussi fâché
je vais pas toucher encore la goutte
d'eau la goutte d'eau qui fait déborder
le subit
inoffensif c'est le régisseur d'alec
baldwin qui nous là
[Rires]
c'est nous la prêtait l'acteur
visiblement fatigué affecté répond pour
la première fois aux questions des
journalistes depuis la mort de la
directrice de la photographie du film
trust
adina hodgins
c'était mon ami c'était mon ami nous
étions une équipe très très soudée mais
cet événement horrible s'est produit il
arrive parfois des accidents sur les
plateaux de tournage mais jamais rien de
tel il y avait une chance sur mille
milliards pour que ça se produise en
2000 eva longoria et obtient son premier
rôle à la télévision dans beverly hills
un rappel
mais mme bah
oui je me rappelle très bien c'est grâce
à cette apparition qu'à se faire opérer
pour jouer après dans les feux de
l'amour ah c'est un bon souvenir c'est
un bon souvenir ça
oui tout à fait c'est un bon souvenir ça
ou pas
non
vous vous demandez sans doute qui est
l'homme le plus cool du monde et on a la
réponse top rank ce mardi l'acteur
faisait tranquillement son jogging sur
une plage de santa monica quand il a
croisé deux jeunes mariés
[Musique]
la star s'est arrêté pour discuter même
prendre quelques photos
oui l'homme le plus cool du monde
définitivement très méchant ah oui c'est
vrai je vais retrouver chez les
escaliers
je tenais je tenais je vais les garder
chez ligier 10 cartes et j'aime pas ça
tous les coups de soirées restent
gravées dans notre mémoire sur la star
academy mais ce 11 novembre c'était un
samedi très particulier parce qu'on
avait sur le même plateau madonna alanis
morissette stevie wonder jaune est
géniale idée mimie mathy
moi j'ai toujours rêvé d'être le sosie
officiel de beyoncé mais mais je plains
mais je parle pas anglais et comme je
parle pas anglais on a mission
officielle de mimie mathy et est en fait
je raconte que c'est compliqué parce que
voilà c'est pas facile d'être le souci
aussi c'est devenu une matière mérité ce
pas ah non on a une région préférée la
note qu'aucun bien sûr parce que je la
porte très bien j'ai chuté
vous l'apporté très bien on confirme
chérie tu te trouves pas que ce jean me
fais un gros cube noir ça ça peut
arriver qu'une femme dit ça à son mari
tous les jours alors le mari vous dites
vous
alors
et bah écoute et raphaël glucksmann à
d'octroi solution
la première solution il peut dire un peu
mais il est mieux que celui qui te fait
un très gros coup ça c'est la solution
soft la bonne nouvelle et y en a une
c'est que vous avez une nouvelle fan
c'est denitsa
denitsa qui adore vos petites fesses
c'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont
exactement ces mots c'est quoi il
souffre le soir je les ai sorti
de secret c'est franchement c'est des
burgers ans
[Rires]
est alors la version la pire des trois
réponses possibles sais c'est pas le
jean qui te fait un gros cul c'est le
nutella craddock n'ont pas écouté crois
que là vraiment
on oublie le prix femina
moi j'adore toujours ses petites fesses
évidemment
cette fois ci les a bien rentrer parce
que je me suis dit est ce que dans tango
argentin qui allait les sortir parce que
c'est vrai qu'elles sont un petit peu
bombé mais tu les aimes bien rentré
alors ça la politique du pitre cyril
hanouna à la une du supplément du monde
et christophe barbier vous savez très
bien que ça aussi c'est une légion
d'honneur oui bien sûr c'est une jour
d'honneur mais ça montre aussi le
trouble de cette famille de presse de
cette famille d'intellectuels qui se dit
mais qu'est ce qui se passe quoi il ya
une france qui nous échappe cyril
hanouna a l'air d'être en contact avec
cette france si on étudie cyril hanouna
on comprendra peut-être cette france ça
manque le désarroi de l'intelligentsia
française désobéir est ce forcément mal
agir
revenons au système de lois
d'abord on vit dans quelque chose qui
s'appelle la démocratie
la démocratie c'est bien le pouvoir du
peu
alors pourquoi ya un président la gauche
le parti socialiste a mis du temps c'est
encore difficile de se relever et de
porter au pardon une ambition donc voilà
c'est pas grave c'est par cet hiver et
ça porte bonheur voilà